[Music]
researchers have discovered 97 new areas
of the brain that were previously
unknown yes there it is true story
having to post in 97 previously unknown
areas of the brain these new regions
control different functions thoughts and
behaviors in all of us I thought once
again would take a look at just a few of
them for example this new region of the
brain remembers whether you like corn or
flour tortillas this region reminds you
to change the station as soon as the DJ
says limp Biskit this region that made
one guy really happy this region used to
contain precious childhood memories but
now it just remembers the names of
pokemons this region makes you pretend
to like jazz this region gives you an
erection for no reason at all this
region makes you coughed to alert others
you're in the bathroom stall
this region decides whether you should
still betting Hugh Grant this region
come on this region won't let you forget
that time you saw one of your Grandpa's
testicles accidentally
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
they get longer it's okay don't blame me
I'm a mine what are you talking about
here
I'm defensive mine
[Laughter]
you